- Seth is just dancing.
We are back with Seth Meyers, Hoda Kotb,
and Jenna Bush Hager, everybody.
(audience clapping and cheering)
It is our official New York City premier,
and we have an audience full
of some of the most vital people in town.
The doormen and women of NYC!
Give it up for yourselves.
(audience cheering and clapping)
In honor of them and in honor of Hoda,
it's time, because her name is awesome
and it goes with this,
we are gonna play a game
called Hoda Da Door.
♪ Hoda Da Door ♪
- Yeah, there's more clever
stuff, New York, coming.
You're welcome.
Here to help us play,
please give it up for another woman
with years of experience
at Rockefeller Center.
She is the host of "Celebrity
Name That Tune on Fox,
Jane Krakowski, everybody!
(upbeat jazzy music)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Jane] Hello.
- [Seth] Good to see you.
- I mean, you might win for outfit.
Your outfit's pretty cute.
It's pretty cute.
- [Hoda] Wow.
- Thank you for being here.
- [Jane] Hello, oh my gosh.
- In you're fabulous
dress I'm gonna steal.
- Thank you, you too.
- Explain the game while we beat them.
- All right, I am, first of all,
I want to say welcome to New York.
I am so happy to have you here, Kelly.
We all are.
And now I'm going to
explain the game to you.
I love playing games,
emotional or otherwise.
- [Kelly] That's fun.
- Okay, we have two teams.
The teams are Kelly and Seth,
- Yes.
- Versus Hoda and Jenna.
- Okay.
- And this game is all about famous doors.
So, I will ask either
one of you a question
about a door or show you a
photo of a door on the screen.
The first team to hit their button
and correctly answer the
question or identify the door,
get it, doormen?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Gets a point.
Okay.
The winning team will earn
a prize for the doormen
on their respective sides of the audience.
- Let's go, guys!
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Kelly] We got it, we got it.
- [Jane] All right, are we ready?
- [Kelly] I'm ready.
- All right, here we go.
- [Kelly] Ooh!
- The first question is,
hidden within a wardrobe, this door led--
- Lion, the Witch and the Wardrobe.
- I know, Narnia!
- No, no, no, Lion, the
Witch and the Wardrobe.
(bell dings)
- [Jane] I am so sorry.
- Let's go!
- No wait, but there's different books!
C.S. Lewis, I read them all.
There's different books.
- [Hoda] They are.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe was in the question.
The answer is Narnia.
- Sorry, Kelly.
I love books.
- We love you.
- I feel like I'm getting
cheated in New York already.
- Welcome to New York City.
- (singing) Welcome to New York.
- Well, okay.
Dang it!
- Okay, here we go.
My kids are gonna be so disappointed.
- This next question,
let's watch the screen.
- Okay.
- The photo will zoom out.
Buzz in when you know what
creature lives behind this door.
(Kelly buzzing)
- Kelly.
- A hobbit.
(bell dings)
- Hobbit is correct!
(audience cheering and clapping)
- [Audience Member] We love you, Kelly!
- I did not hear someone
shout that from the audience.
- The great news is I did,
and I thought they said
rabbit, so I'm glad I not...
- Alright, next question.
- Okay.
- One to one.
Well done, teams.
- [Hoda] You're welcome.
- This door was a fa--
(Seth buzzes)
- Is that who, is that?
Jim Morrison.
- Wait, wait, we had it!
(bell dings)
- [Seth] Oh, I'm sorry.
I apologize.
- I guess we're giving it to you,
because you said the answer out loud?
- No, no, that's okay.
That's okay, he got it.
- All right, Seth got it, okay, great.
(bell dings)
- I feel bad about it, but I did get it.
- All right, next question.
- Okay.
- St. Peter sits and judges
those walking into the next life.
(Hoda buzzes)
- We know.
Heaven's Gate?
- Heaven's Gate.
(bell dings)
- We will accept that.
Heaven's Gate or the Pearly Gates.
- [Hoda] The Pearly Gates.
- Yes, well done.
All right.
Are we ready for the next one?
- Ready.
- All right.
Take a look at the screen again.
- Okay, okay.
- Buzz in when you know who
had to enter this chamber
and face a magical test.
(Kelly buzzes)
- Chamber of Secrets!
Harry Potter.
(bell dings)
- That is correct.
- Yes!
(audience cheering and clapping)
Yes!
- That's a good door, that's
a good door right there.
That's a good famous door.
- That's a scary door, and a good one.
- You're getting into Heaven,
I'm getting into Hogwarts.
It's great, it's great.
- Oh, you're so competitive, I love it.
- I love it.
- It's one of my favorite doors.
All right, here we go.
In a certain horror
movie, what actor broke
down a door with an ax and
announced Johnny was here?
(Seth buzzes)
- Jack Nicholson.
- [Jenna] Jack Nicholson.
(bell dings)
- That is correct.
- Oh, I didn't know if
you had to say the movie.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- The problem is...
- Come on, we're ready.
- This is the elevator door
in a famous building in New York City.
Buzz in when you know the building.
(Hoda and Seth buzzing)
- Empire State Building.
- Yeah.
- Yes, so fast!
- I just got here.
I just got here, I didn't know that one.
(doorbell ringing)
- Oh.
- Okay, that sound
means that we have to go
to the final question, which
will be worth three points.
- Oh, so we could win still.
- The score is four to three,
but it's still anyone's game.
This one is worth three points.
- Okay, okay.
- All right, this is another visual clue.
When you can name the movie
in which this cold damp door was featured,
buzz in and let's see it.
- [Seth] Who is that?
(Kelly buzzes)
- Edward Scissorhands?
No, sorry.
(buzzer blares)
- The Titanic!
- Yeah.
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] Oh.
- It was the Titanic.
(bell dings)
(audience cheering and clapping)
(sound horn blaring)
- She looked like Edward
Scissorhands this close.
Okay, it doesn't matter
'cause it's my show
and we're here in New York
and everyone in the audience
is getting this.
You may know our partners, the iconic food
and drink ware brand, Stanley,
and their TikTok famous quencher,
the emotional support water bottle.
It's lovely.
All their products are
sustainable and reusable,
which is awesome.
And the studio audience is
going to know that firsthand
because you're all getting a
$250 gift card for Stanley.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Yes.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Thank you so much to Jane
for Krakowski for hosting.
Remember to watch her show,
"Celebrity Name That Tune,"
Tuesday nights on Fox.
We'll be right back.